bonsoir bonsoir par les français
non ça s'arrête et costaud un bon
reflète
pas le faire chier j'ai dit à ses
intérêts de sympa avec lui cinoche
alors vous connais comme acteur de
cinéma surtout grâce au fameux piège en
haute mer évidemment ce film nous a
propulsé au rang de star planétaire
au même titre que sylvester stallone ou
arnold scharzenegger
mais ce que beaucoup de gens ignorent
stevens et que derrière cette violence
se cache un être profondément spirituel
des bouddhistes depuis 20 ans et tous
les jours vous faites une heure de
méditation le matin et une heure de
méditation le soir et deux heures de
coups de boule derrière pour garder la
forme
disons que je connaisse bouddhisme
depuis des années 60 donc ça peut être
plus donnent plus de 20 ans fait
plus de vingt ans que je pratique le
bouddhisme je suis allé en asie en 1969
et là j'étais déjà boutiste c'était un
peu plus de vingt ans qu effectivement
je pratique le bouddhisme oui
apparemment ça vous met dans un état
formidable vous avez l'air très cool zen
vers
la soirée est cool c'est à côté d'une
superbe jeune femme
donc c'est cool effectivement nous
sommes cool
vais pas il est à côté
alors plusieurs fois par an vous partez
en pèlerinage en inde steven
donne à des bidounes août également à
bengalore à mysore bien sûr nous allons
au tibet
boutanos himalayens
vous avez rencontré le dalaï lama et ça
vous a profondément changé non
disons que je me connais depuis plus de
vingt ans maintenant
et ce sont ses maîtres qui sont devenus
les miens
et du rock aussi
annoncé du blues situe plus quittée il
ya aussi d'aïkido qui vous êtes beaucoup
à l'aïkido je sais pas si vous savez ce
que c'est bérénice c'est un art martial
qui permet une vraie synergie du corps
et de l'esprit et l'autre ami steven et
7e dan en aïkido c'est le de desbuquois
15 minutes comme il dit à peu près
d'expérience sur un poste et vous en
faites depuis l'âge de 7 ans un
fait là j'ai commencé le karaté à 7 ans
le like it où j'ai commencé
j'avais 15 ans à peu près 15 16 ans et
vous avez étudié tout ça au japon avec
des grands maîtres
un peu partout en asie mais j'ai vécu au
japon de nombreuses années près de vingt
ans
voilà alors donc tout le monde le prend
pour un acteur de films d'action en fait
il est bouddhiste il est très très zen
est ce que peu de gens savent c'est la
musique c'est à dire que steven seagal
fait de la musique j'ai commencé tout la
musique j'ai commencé à l'âge de 5 ans
non
exactement
au début c'était là tri puis la guitare
la guitare la jeune 9 10 ans et voilà
vous avez joué ces dernières années avec
des légendes vivantes comme bbking comme
si les wonder
oui
c'est un peu du rnb qui peut il et il
est sur mon dernier album non plutôt mon
avant dernier album sur le dernier album
il y avait beau délits du berceau mullen
koko taylor
c'est dire que presque toutes les
légendes vivantes en tout cas demain et
c'est vrai que stevie wonder dans la
ville voit très bien fait des marques et
[Rires]
quelquefois on se bagarre un petit peu
et m'attrape il fait semblant de 2 me
trancher la gorge des choses comme ça
maintenant j'ai un peu l'impression
effectivement qu'il est réellement avec
le camp gbagbo
voilà alors si vous avez passé beaucoup
de temps à faire du cinéma j'ai fait
beaucoup de films en tant qu'acteur en
tant que réalisateur et vous avez un
petit peu laissé tomber la musique à
cause de ça et sur son i devant votre
mère vous a fait promettre de
commercialiser votre musique
d'inscrits
voilà alors steven seagal sera le 13
septembre à l'olympia à part égale et le
14 septembre au palais des congrès je ne
fais pas la cigale c'est qu'ils me
why did we go on aurait dû elle est là
c'est quand même c'est quand même
dommage matin brun est pas là en
omettant d'y aller alors la france je
l'aimé bien c'est un peu votre pays de
coeur la france
l'ofs et comment j'adore la france pour
voir ce à cause des petites françaises
à cause de quoi
absolument les petites français ça ouais
là coup sûr y'a pas que ça quand même
waouh
bon à part les filles pourquoi vous
aimez la france tienne
les garçons
quand même la culture et puis est
beaucoup plus de liberté dans ce pays
sur le plan culturel en tout cas on a
l'impression que même la presse est plus
libre la façon dont on considère là
c'est très différent ici mais en tout
cas très différents de ce qu'on trouve
en amérique par exemple c'est une espèce
de melting-pot justement en france
depuis plusieurs centaines d'années vous
avez des peuples du monde entier qui se
sont retrouvés ici c'est un pays
extraordinaire
pourquoi justement découvrir toute cette
diversité découvrir ses propres pensées
à travers tout cela j'adore jouer ici
essayé ma musique ici parce que
justement il ya cette diversité
culturelle cette diversité d'époque elle
s'auto plus de liberté pour un artiste
vous êtes très tendre
ce n'est pas la brute épaisse qu'on voit
dans les films tu fais un bisou
justement interview t'embrasse
[Musique]
il s'appelait comment votre ours en
peluche
harold ça a été dur quand on vous a dit
que le père noël n'existait pas
j'ai pleuré deux semaines d'affilée et
puis ensuite essayé de me suicider si je
me suis ensuite
et j'ai disparu plusieurs années je me
suis remotivé en fait c'était mon
premier voyage au tibet vous disiez
souvent je t'aime à votre maman non non
vous lui faisiez quoi comme cadeau quand
vous étiez petit coup de bol
quand j'étais petit on visait que plutôt
que d'aller dans une boutique acheter un
cadeau avec l'argent de poche il valait
mieux faire deux choses quelque chose de
nos mains parce qu'ils s'amenaient du
coeur comme ça et donc souvent j'ai
essayé de fabriquer des choses pour ma
famille pour mes parents pour montrer
mon affection
et ma gratitude
c'est quand la dernière fois vous avez
dit je t'aime à une femme
il ya deux secondes je crois
qu'elle est l'endroit le plus romantique
que vous ayez fait d'amour
probablement au japon vous avez été
mariée au japon dans la salle absolument
oui
c'était il ya longtemps un oui déjà
pleuré pour une fille
tous les jours il est doux et super
sympa super sympa j'aime pas sa veste et
pour un garçon pour un garçon vous avez
déjà pleuré
oui après tout moi j'ai pleuré lorsque
des amis hommes à moi sont fait tuer par
exemple elle s'appelait comment votre
première petite amie boylan menad
couronne bac
pas celle dont je me souviens en tout
cas la première dont je me souvienne
c'est étonnant qu'elle s'appelait tom
stone à la tonne à donnacona
la brise de mer qui n'a jamais accusé de
ça encore ouais c'est ce soir
vous voulez un bisou
m
ok
[Musique]
high
flight aziz bâ dégâts
j ch est ce que régis est là parce que
la petite fille était parmi eux
attention régis vous devez affronter mon
garde du corps au bras de fer
c'est tombé sur toi à l'aise y attends
je mets 15 euros sur le gros ils sont
tous les deux je me comprends
le très gros bon attention vous êtes
prêt régis
rebecca attention one minute
attention attention one two three
[Musique]
allez-y
et
break et ça paraît
qsi la commune
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu